hey guys just want to let you know all
merch is restocked we've got the night
pants we got the night pants nation
joggers hoodies tees night shorts all of
it
is back in stock head over to the
honeydew merch store and get your
honeydew gear today
[Applause]
hey guys just want to tell you uh the
night pants nation tour kicks off next
month i can't tell you how excited i am
to get out there this is more gratitude
tour um than anything honestly i've sat
here for the last year and a half in
this room and we built the [ __ ] army
and i'm coming out to see you all i
can't thank you enough for your support
so let's have some fun together here are
the dates september 16th to 18th i'm in
phoenix arizona september 30th to
october 2nd indianapolis indiana october
23rd baltimore maryland october 28th
brea california november 12th through
the 13th arlington virginia december 9th
through the 11th cleveland ohio december
17th through the 20th la jolla
california january 6th to the 8th austin
texas january 20th to the 22nd kansas
city missouri february 17th to the 19th
we're in vancouver march 17th to the
19th
edmonton all right and there are a bunch
of dates i'm jumping out to do with tom
segura as well go to ryansickler.com
click on that night pants nation tour
info and get your tickets
this episode of the honeydew is brought
to you by expressvpn freshly and sheath
more on that later let's get into the
duke the honeydew with ryan zickler
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
studios i'm ryan sickler ryan
sickler.com you heard the announcement
go to ryansickler.com get your night
pants nation tour tickets today
i mean tom's coming everywhere i'm
coming everywhere behind him you know
what i'm saying uh and i will be doing
some dates with tom so come out and see
us come out and see me let's have some
fun i can't thank you all enough
um the honeydewpodcast.com is the
website for the show please subscribe to
the youtube channel you guys we have a
growing army over there right now all
right we're over 113 000 i think now you
watch and you like it it's free hit
subscribe it means nothing to you and
everything to me okay patreon another
community that continues to grow and
blow me away with stories okay if you or
someone you know has that story that has
to be heard please submit it to
honeydewpodcast gmail.com we'll vet it
hopefully we'll get to do an episode
together uh it's five bucks a month okay
and if you sign up for your year you get
over a month free and you are getting
the honeydew a day early ad-free at no
additional charge all right uh ringtones
we're working on the android now we're
gonna be able to try to put it on the
direct website and you'll be able to buy
from there but for those of you who do
have apple they're available in the
itunes store
uh there's three or four of them i think
and um i love hearing that you guys are
buying the [ __ ] out of them i can't
i can't get over it so go there uh some
of you had trouble finding them if you
go to itunes store you just search my
name
scroll down click on ringtones they're
right there okay honeydew athletes we
got four in the stable right now all
right we got four in the stable first
guy here marcus everett this dude is a
bowfisherman he's a beast this kid here
kaden wood
d2
pitcher for seton hill went to the
college uh world series all right beck
adler so my boy you might have seen him
on uh the honeydew with y'all also gary
adler's son
kid's a killer big wave surfer and then
we got maverick reed professional cowboy
over here he's a bull rider y'all so
those are our athletes right now we're
adding to uh our little stable um i did
get some d1 requests so let me look at
them if you're a walk-on then hell yeah
all right hell yeah if you got a full
ride hell no
hell
no all right y'all you know what we do
over here we highlight the low lights
these are the stories behind the
storytellers you know it's easy to show
your highlights in life on your little
social media and stuff it's not so easy
to highlight your lowlights all right so
we're gonna sit down today and listen to
this storyteller who's got an incredible
story ladies and gentlemen please
welcome for the first time here on the
honeydew chris boyer y'all welcome to
the honeydew
thanks for having me bro thank you for
having me uh thank you for being here
and for having me i guess i still have
me at your table i wouldn't have anybody
else thank you bro it's nice to be here
uh before we get into what we're gonna
talk about today will you please plug
promote everything uh yeah you can find
me on twitter and instagram at i am
chris porter uh
i have a website chrisportercomedy.com
has all my tour dates coming up i'll be
in uh toledo
uh
[ __ ] other places uh
there's a san jose date that we're
holding on to but let's be honest
probably not gonna happen
uh but yeah that's chrisportercomedy.com
and that's uh that's pretty much and
also i'm on spotify and pandora and i've
got
four specials on amazon yeah that's all
four specials on amazon yeah yeah go
watch all of that um all right so this
is
like this is some the story i heard
about a little while ago i've known you
for a while now in comedy going back to
your long curly hair days yeah and uh i
heard about this tumor or or this injury
you had excuse me yeah i say tumor
because i know it's brain but i misspoke
um and i heard it was golf related and
you and i have never
like you had full-on brain surgery like
the the whole deal can we talk about
because you said
that afterwards you went into a
depression that you've never really
talked about and i'd like to talk about
what happened yeah take us to that day
okay so the day of uh me and my mom went
to play golf it was a i think it was a
monday night how old are you i'm 17
and your mom's golfing with you so are
you like a golf family because i know
you're still into it especially that
time like my mom was starting to get
into it a lot and so was i i think i was
three years in four years in
so i remember i'd been out at the lake
with my friend buddies all weekend just
being
just
uh it was table rock okay but you're
from kansas city well yeah so
good guess but we went to the mr pibb
lake
not the doctor
dr pepper lake you know what i'm saying
so
yeah i know what you're saying uh so you
know and we were doing the dumbest [ __ ]
in the world we were jumping out of
boats doing 30 miles an hour just being
17 year old idiots and then
monday rolls around mom's like i got
free golf you want to go play golf i go
[ __ ] yeah second hole i'm
you know mom was very much about the
rules so while she hit i stood off the
fairway parallel with her and then this
ball just
whack
uh right about an inch above the temple
and i went down
i can tell you this the dick the moment
i got hit
the moment i got hit i s i had a vision
of a ball being hit off a t
and uh i went down and i
i would if i was out at all it was for a
split second
and i get up and my head [ __ ] hurt
am i bleeding is it not bleeding there's
is there a [ __ ]
there's hope there i mean immediately no
uh and we're [ __ ] butted [ __ ] it hurt
and did you the person come over so the
person comes over well first my mom i
had just gotten contacts for the first
time so i'm like rubbing my head and my
mom thinks i'm just [ __ ] with my
contacts she goes what's wrong she
didn't see it no she didn't see it she i
got hit
and so she comes screaming over
and this old man comes around it's a dog
leg he didn't see me and he should have
been trying to hit around my mom in the
first place you know old white men
uh
so
he comes around i'm
[ __ ] i rolled that woman's car and
i've still never seen
her yell at a man
[Laughter]
the way she's i mean she went full
gorilla just
like
it wasn't even words it was just emotion
and this dude was frightened and i
thought i was fine how old do you think
this guy was 60s 70s
and like
my mom looks at me and she goes are you
okay i'm like yeah i'm fine and
part of the hole
go
i was talking all mad [ __ ] about that i
was like look at that bob got hit still
partying you're not seeing double it's
just throbbing this is all you're
getting is pain but about five holes
deep
[ __ ] changes headache gets worse i start
seeing double i line up to the t marker
instead of my ball
mom's like yeah we're gonna get out of
here so we leave
and now there's a bump
and then all of a sudden the bumps gone
and my head hurt so i go home mom's on
the phone mom's on the phone the
hospital i'm calling my buddy and he's
like you don't sound right man
and i'm like well i sound fine he's like
no you don't really he could hear it
yeah he was like you know you're like
slurring your words or you don't i don't
know he's like buddy you don't sound
right and this is a 17 year old kid
and i was like all right and then
then it got real bad like the headache
was just
it
i mean i've never felt pain like it
since and
i started seeing double and i was like
yeah i think we need are you vomiting or
anything not at this point
as soon as we get to the hospital we get
to triage and they're like what's wrong
i just threw up all over the desk
let's take a minute
no wait for that guy
so just fyi if you want to get through
the line just fire one out
so
i get back there uh
they run cat scan they they're like okay
there's a blood what has happened is the
blood is it cracked your skull the blood
is
seeped back through the crack it is now
clotting between your brain and your
skull whoa okay so that's that's why the
headache is so much worse now
and uh so
doctor comes in i got real lucky that
the number one neurosurgeon in kansas
city happened to be on call that night
and this dude walks in and this dude was
[ __ ] iceman just
comes in he's like this is what we need
to do i need to cut open your head and
we just need to go in there and get the
brain thing out and then you'll be good
as new and i was like
but he said it so he didn't come in like
er
he was just like this is what has
happened so he said it's so low key i
was just like so well anyway
football starts in two weeks
and i started my junior year so i had a
starting spot guarantee i'm like i'm not
a position uh split in okay because we
ran up offense from [ __ ] 1947.
yeah yeah a lot of options
so you'd be a pro bowler every year if
you were split into the nfl the only
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
so
uh
i go hey man uh football starts in two
weeks and let's just do it at the end of
the season and he's like nobody you
don't understand if you don't do this
tonight you won't be here tomorrow
tonight and i go you're not even getting
a week to prepare you're going in that
night he's like if you don't do this
tonight you won't be here tomorrow and
i'm out of it tomorrow
i go of course i won't be here tomorrow
i'm going to leave why would i stay here
and he's like and he puts his head and
he's like buddy
here's what's going to happen the blood
will continue to clot around your brain
and you will die one of the most
horrifyingly painful deaths that
anyone's ever died ever
and then the doctor said
that
that was the gist of it you know yeah
and uh
and he goes and i go well then why
why are we even quite why'd you even
give me the option and he was like yeah
we need to get in there and do this so
went in there did it i was in intensive
care for two days wait how long did the
surgery take
i mean i would say i went in in the
afternoon i mean he's basically what now
re he's resealing the crow he's
carrying your skull they basically took
a hole saw
drilled out what we did over here in the
court in the right corners to have cable
run through for real for real i took a
hole saw holy [ __ ] plugging drilled out
that's this side took out a piece of my
skull
took out the clot put the piece of skull
back in and then put three wires in that
and then the
they fuse to the bone as the bone begins
to fuse to itself and then that it all
heals itself it all heals itself and uh
i told the story on another podcast but
one of the wires had a
was a little loose and it would make a
clicking sound swear to god and
what do you mean like you're just
gonna do here
swear to god
listen i know you're nervous man uh i
can hear your head click
during a test
in high school the next year i'm sitting
here i'm clicking away not that anyone
can hear it and the girl next to me goes
can anyone else hear this [ __ ]
[ __ ] shot i was like oh okay
i'm sorry
sorry it's my wife
got
that's ridiculous so
she's mad
so i remember i went back to get my
stitches out wait so hold on hold on
you're in for quite a while i mean
intensive care for two days do you
remember coming out of this i do
remember coming in i remember because i
had knee surgery and i remember coming
out of it not not being i remember they
were talking about my teeth like oh you
have nice teeth in it nothing yeah no i
woke up and i remember like trying to
put the pieces together in my head it
really went from we need to have like
the story i just told you like and then
it's like this weird like star wipe too
it's for you for me but what is is your
mom a mess the whole family shows up
apparently everybody you know a lot of
people are crying people are freaking
out how about the old dude
nowhere to be found like because again
that's not your mom's he's at the bar
having beers going i [ __ ] hit this
kid it was crazy
give me a double
you're a miner too yeah you're a miner
so
i uh so i wake up about
it all i know is that the clock on the
wall says four something
and my old man is [ __ ] reading a
paper and sitting there and i go
i was just like is it so i get choked up
when i remember that and uh
i was like yo what's up and he's like
what's up
what is it 4am or 4pm he goes am i going
what the [ __ ] are you doing here
and he goes i'm making sure you're all
right i'm your dad yeah i'm your dad you
just went through brains or brain cert
well yeah skull surgery so uh
so yeah two days
so this is all two weeks before high
school starts so can i ask you a
question because i keep saying is it
considered brain surgery if they if they
i mean to me it is yeah i think once
they cracked the screen anything on the
head
is brain surgery uh at least [ __ ]
stitches
brain adjacent
braided jake
uh but yeah so two days in intensive
care you know everyone shows up you know
then two days in a regular hospital
everyone shows up and visits all your
friends and is your head like swimming
like crazy it's just in a big turban
okay
and then they come in day four and take
all the bandages off and they're like
give me like a piece of underwear to
wear over my head so two days icu two
days regular house hospital and then
you're out then i'm out your [ __ ]
head just got a hole cut in it and four
days later you're back into the wild
yeah well not like out like go have fun
see it oh yeah but i mean out of that
building yeah yeah they're like get the
[ __ ] out of here not much more we can do
and so then it was like two weeks of
like bed rest and not being able to do
anything and being on a show are you in
crazy paint yeah
no i don't remember a lot of pain being
involved i i don't there might have been
i just don't remember that part of it
and then
you know and then high school starts and
i went to a rural high school you're a
senior that year senior that year
so football's gone
they are they told me they're like
you're split ends jobs they're like
you're done
so i tried to be like a manager for like
two weeks i was like this sucks this
sucks because i couldn't really hang out
with the players and then you couldn't
and the coaches when they wanted to talk
they wouldn't you wanted they didn't
want you around
so i was like [ __ ] this so
uh and then
and then yeah man like i'd say
how long are you like when you start
school are you do you still have a head
wrap or i got a head wrap i got i don't
have stitches anymore but there's a
pretty mac i was the only kid in high
school to wear that was able to wear a
hat
okay so that you wear a hat over there
like yeah because i went to again it was
1996 so it was a long time ago yeah it
was and they wouldn't let you we didn't
we weren't allowed to wear hats at
school
and so yeah we couldn't either we
couldn't in our high school so they were
like yeah you can wear a hat because no
one wants to [ __ ] stare at that all
the
time
not for yourself not for you literally
for all of us so we don't have to look
at that your [ __ ] frankenstein face
because you ever realize this [ __ ] went
from here
to here yeah you can i see it like yeah
you can so they cut you from there to
there from here all the way to here and
then what did they pull your face down
yeah yeah that's [ __ ] nuts my buddy
came in they do pictures of it do you
have any pictures pictures well i have a
picture i posted on instagram of me with
the stitches yeah and that's what made
me say okay i got it he's got to come
tell this [ __ ] yeah so that happens and
then
so how long are you in this headdress i
don't know i would say i'm dressing a
month or two
damn really yeah just because i mean it
was a pretty heavy
gash so can you sleep at night
comfortably yeah i was on so many drugs
i was sleeping during the day sleeping
at night
um how are your grades during then just
[ __ ] no they were
i only had to do half a year that year
because my parents thought i was moving
my parents thought we were moving to new
york
so i i elevate or i accelerated my high
school program so like my junior year i
took like senior classes so i could
graduate a little bit early
and we never ended up moving but so my
senior year i came in like i got half a
year and i'm
[ __ ] just walking
so i did that
um
i had already done my senior paper my
junior year so i was like [ __ ] this
is gonna be a cake walk and it was
and uh i was out i think i was out my
senior year by like 11 30.
and so that was fun and then once the
depression really started to kick in
uh about seven months in
and i moved and it was when i left home
to go to ku
and
you know i just i was in this place like
it was really starting i just thought i
was 18 and going through it and also
like we came up in that kurt cobain era
we did and so like kurt's when he killed
himself like i had a buddy kill himself
like a year later and you know and he
idolized that dude and all hey his high
school girlfriend broke up with it right
and he goes and [ __ ] and offs himself
that's why yeah man
and it's [ __ ] yeah that doesn't have
he doesn't have that idea if kurt does
and not kurt had serious demons and
probably had every reason in his brain
to do what he did
but
there were repercussions to his actions
yeah and for a lot of people in our
generation
and so and i saw that and
so when i went through this heavy
depression and you do wake up every day
what's going on when what do you notice
first when you realize man this this is
different i know things are different i
would wake up and say [ __ ]
that's the first first fear dress like
[ __ ] man like i woke up is it cause you
oh i woke up not [ __ ] another day of
this [ __ ] no i was like [ __ ] i woke up
oh you really wanted to die
yeah but i didn't know why like life was
good like i have a great
family well the drugs i'm sure were part
of it i mean i'm off the truck no i mean
the prescription that [ __ ] [ __ ] with
you for sure
um but also you're you lost your
football that year yeah you lost your
senior year of high school you're losing
like a lot of these kids now with kova
their senior year is gone yeah um so
that's tough and then not i get it man
trying to stay around the guys and be
the manager on the football team and
like [ __ ] this yeah and then like that
that to me would would really [ __ ] with
me so i would start to like you know
obviously i hadn't found comedy yet
i mean i'm six months from finding
comedy at this point
uh but like
i've always been into music so i start
writing songs they're just trying to
find a way to like get out of it but i
all my high school like i grew up with a
bunch of jocks in the country and there
it was all machismo and like i was like
the black sheep that had feelings and
[ __ ]
you know like listen to like good music
and
because like i felt it you know and so i
remember i wrote this song called i hate
myself
which like in the 90s
there were a lot of songs that were very
close to basically that same thing so i
wasn't really going out on a limb but
i was like hey you guys i wrote this
song and i sang him for him and they're
like you [ __ ] hate yourself like what
the [ __ ] wrong like it was that like
yeah like your trainer it was like david
goggins being like you [ __ ] hate
yourself yeah you gotta get your inner
[ __ ]
i wrote uh one in seventh grade about my
mom called cloven hoof [ __ ]
that's true dude yeah
and the lunch lady read it
she goes can i see that she hand it to
me she goes
okay
due in my high school my or my college
roommate was super like
[ __ ] really bad bipolar and so like
i'd tell him but it's like yeah no i
feel the same way and i'm just like well
this isn't helping
you're not the guy i want to do you know
you're snug now you're just we're
starting to outline our letters no this
isn't good
and so like it there were dark nights
and you know
there were
yeah there was one night in particular
you searched the house for
and
a way to do it and what would you have
done
oh i would have used a shotgun are you
serious yeah yeah
and it got to a point where i knew the
gun and i just didn't have the
ammunition
did you talk to your parents about this
at all not till years after years yeah
yeah yeah so you just suffered
internally and did you go to therapy no
therapy no therapy and they didn't send
it to you to you to therapy after a
brain surgery or anything like that no
and as a matter of fact i didn't find
out that the depression was related to
the brain surgery until years later when
i was talking to a neurosurgeon at a bar
really and i just i was like oh and i
told him the story he's like do you go
through a big depression after that i go
he just asked on his own yeah and i go i
go yeah but i was 18 and in college my
first year who doesn't he's like nah man
that was
major brain trauma will [ __ ] you up i
bet and so
you know and i didn't have any answers
and i didn't
i knew in my mind that i had no reason
to do it like life was great i'd had
you know my you know a lot of comics you
know their crux comes from like a bad
relationship with their parents or
whatever that or whatever their internal
struggle is my internal struggle has
always just been a lack of confidence
that is
ingrained in me
like from where where is that coming i
don't know but it's not for my family
because my family's very supportive and
loving and your mom was out there
driving the [ __ ] out
but like me and my mom and dad talk
every [ __ ] day so you know like we my
family is amazing and so it's just
always been and i see it a lot on some
of my dad's side of the family and they
they all are medicated i just
josh wolfe and i talk about this all the
time i have
what is how do we say this all the time
like i say it all the time and i got
this brain fog but it's like i wish my
um
self-confidence
matched my
belief in myself
you know what i'm saying because you're
obviously a doer you're out there
getting it done you're successful like i
believe
i can do something i believe in myself
but my self-confidence about
my appearance who i am talking all that
that is always lacked it's always lacked
which is why
i try to be funny to make up for it
somebody the other day this [ __ ] made me
i don't know who you are but i want you
to know i saw it and i laughed my ass
off but they said
if an afternoon nap had a face it would
be ryan's
is that not the greatest
they're in the comic we work with that
could do better than that dude
nailed it i'll tell you what i'm proud
of i'll not be able to take him out
afterwards anymore without thinking of
your dumb thing you're sleeping my face
will just be floating above you
[ __ ] yeah man uh so
like and i knew that going so like
self-confidence has always been an issue
and i think that maybe is the a lot of
the reason i am such a doer and i am is
because i don't if i don't do things i
don't i already don't think i'm great so
if i don't do things to like let others
worse
yeah it does not help the situation at
all so it's
so that i i knew that so i just thought
maybe being at 18 even i had the
self-awareness to be like you know
you're kind of a [ __ ] anyway inside
like you have a major for you yeah you
have a major inner [ __ ] and like you
wear it well
i didn't wear it well at [ __ ] 17 i
wear it much better now
uh don't you wish you could look back
now but listen [ __ ] you just
survived a traumatic brain injury yeah
like you could have died but even today
like
i have
i've done a lot of [ __ ] that a lot of
comics haven't been able to do
through whether i'm because of my talent
or because of luck or whatever it is but
even last night i did a show
at the improv
and the girl in front of me did well and
i was immediately like i'm [ __ ] i'm
gonna eat [ __ ] i'm gonna eat a giant
dick up there
and i and that happens every time and
you've been doing comedy how long 22
[ __ ] yeah for people that want to
hear
that's right 22 years every time i write
a new joke i'm like that's not funny
it's not funny enough
and then i go up on stage i was like
well i guess i was wrong but also that's
what makes you good you know you're you
don't go to your first thought our job
isn't to write our first thought our job
is to
dive way deeper than that and still
somehow
take something that you've heard talked
about before in a way or style that has
hasn't been done yeah and i think that
that is relatable and that only happens
if you are your true self about that
it's taken me
i mean i once read richard pryor say
like i don't know was 10 or 15 years to
be to find your real self on stage and
that that's when i read that i was like
good god but man podcasting
has changed my stand up my everything
you know once you start talking about
your real life [ __ ] it's like are you
talking about that on stage where you
should
yeah you know well [ __ ] yeah and then
that has helped me become myself more
than anything i don't know if i stay
with just stand up if i would have got
to my true self as quick as i would i
have through
the addition of podcasting yeah does
that make sense 100
i uh well what's weird is stand-up ended
up saving me
from well that's all i was going to get
at because i meant you mentioned six
months after the depression you find
stand-up and it so how does that happen
so
i just i found like a creative outlet
that
look i was 19 i wasn't this still not
the smoothest guy with the ladies i mean
i was a professional comic before i
wasn't a virgin
wait what i had been paid to do comedy
before you lost your virginity before i
lost my virgin i you know it wasn't much
it was like 50 bucks but i mean that
that gives you the first time that gives
you a timeline is like my life like
high school was not the only reason i
was cool in high school was because i
played sports and i was decent at them
and i i don't know if that's why i still
[ __ ] work out and play sports all the
time it probably is but
um
yeah i the only reason i didn't get my
ass whooped in high school is because i
had all i had so much protection
just the older jocks would i remember
walking into high school football games
or like away basketball games and like
the seniors coming up and like hey if
anyone [ __ ] with you you just let us
know all right yeah but even then i
didn't i had no co i had zero confidence
right you'd think i'd be like what up
[ __ ] you i got carte blanche but i was
still like no i'm still
so
yeah i just um
i forgot where i was going with this
uh it's just i've never really talked
about a lot of this so it's weird
um
you were talking about how you first
found comedy yeah so saved you so my
buddy calls
and he goes i'm going to do stand-up
comedy
this isn't is this in kansas kansas city
and this dude was like the dude
he just watched movies and he'd want to
be that movie like and he was just crazy
enough to do that [ __ ] like
swingers came out had suits also knew
how to ballroom dance [ __ ] everybody
was money
uh so he saw the punch line or something
like that and
it was 97 he [ __ ] pulls out a phone
book and opens up to comedy clubs
there's one
and he calls him because i want to be a
stand-up comic how do i do it and they
[ __ ] told him and so i show up and i
watch him do open mic night
and how old are you now i'm 18 at this
point 19
i'm 19 uh because it was the summer of
98 and
i watched him do it
and i just happened to be just
happenstance they sent me front row
center
so i had like the view and i watched 24
comics go up damn yeah remember those
days remember those days
three minutes a piece yeah holy [ __ ] and
uh and a host in between that would do
way too much time yeah for no reason for
no reason
just riffing on whatever shitty joke you
just heard so
and i just remember going i'm funnier
than half these people
and my mom had all i i come from a line
of musicians
and so like and at that time their
success was nominal
uh now come to now like my uncles had a
great band and made very good money but
at that at that time my mom always
warned me like you don't want to be a
musician
it's it's a hard road and very few
people get in i was like well this is
comedy i don't have to get a band
together i it's just me
and uh
and i [ __ ] it was the greatest
the moment i stepped on stage and got
that first laugh it was now the greatest
thing ever physically healed i'm
physically healed at that point fully
this uh what did you have staples out
here uh stitches stitches they're
removed they're removed and my hair
isn't quite as receded at the time so a
lot of hair is covering it by this point
and you
feel all right you're comfortable about
getting up in front of people with that
too i mean yeah like you couldn't see it
you couldn't see it at depth i mean it's
very visible now but this was 22 years
on a probably about an inch of hairline
uh ago
so and that just was the greatest
feeling in the world it was and also
when you're actually coming out of that
to be
just to receive that yeah and just to
have that but that rush and that energy
and that's it and it was like this is
the in
and it was before sex it was the
greatest thing that ever
occurred to me and even when it was
and then i went up the next time and
[ __ ] bumped but even in the moment of
bombing i was like this is still amazing
and i have to do this and uh
and i was
man when you get a chance to scream into
a microphone for three minutes every
once in a while you you stop being as
depressed as you are i'll bet and also
you just
do you remember do you remember what you
were talking about then would you talk
any did you do anything being a virgin
okay uh did you do anything about your
no i still have not been able to make
that really you still don't do anything
on it i still have not been able to like
i've tried a couple of times to write it
out and it's just
um
i don't i
i think you just need to share it as a
story and find spots in the story to to
bring humor i maybe that's it i don't
you know maybe i've become over the
years i have become more of a
storytelling comic
so maybe it's time to maybe revisit it i
mean it's the time i almost died yeah
it is
but uh
yeah doctor's over eating a sandwich
he's like listen you gotta get this [ __ ]
done like in 30 minutes but i would like
to say this it's the greatest thing to
have ever happened to me
that's that's really
because it's great to hear
that you have that outlook on it why
because it puts you into comedy put me
in the comedy i was going into the navy
like i was so you had oh i was already
talking to recruiters i was going into
mrotc yeah me too uh i i still have my
letters of recommendation
all that [ __ ] and i was it was set i was
gonna
go to college
go to office to school or go to boot
camp go to office to school be in the
navy for five years and then [ __ ]
walk out with like
some weird some degree
and uh and then the sky was the limit at
that point and it was it was set and
then i i wa some of some of the
depression may come from
having a plan and then that plan just
being ripped away from you sure um yeah
you had this whole thing but also i
would have left officer school
may of 2001
so just in time for granted i would have
been in the navy i would have been
[ __ ] on a boat watching it happen but
still i would have gone straight to
straight to war yeah you would have and
um instead i went and had sex with a
bunch of girls i
would never have had sex with
had i not been funny
let's take a quick break and tell you
about our first sponsor expressvpn using
the internet without expressvpn is like
driving without car insurance why take
that risk why does everyone need a vpn
because every time you connect to an
unencrypted network like in cafes hotels
or airports any hacker on the same
network can gain access to your personal
data your passwords your financial
details all that stuff and it doesn't
take much technical knowledge to hack
someone just some cheap hardware a smart
12 year old could do it your data is
valuable hackers can make up to a
thousand dollars a person selling
personal info on the dark web here's why
you need to use expressvpn expressvpn
acts as an online insurance it creates a
secure encrypted tunnel between your
device and the internet hackers cannot
steal your personal data it is super
secure it would take a hacker with a
super computer over a billion years to
get past express vpn's encryption and
it's super simple you just fire up the
app you click one button to get
protected it works on all your devices
your phones your laptops your tablets
and more so you can stay secure on the
go we use it here at the studio i use it
at home we're not leaving our stuff
exposed all right secure your online
data today by visiting expressvpn.com
honeydew that's e-x-p-r-e-s-s
vpn.com honeydew and you can get an
extra three months for free
expressvpn.com
honeydew
our next sponsor is freshly now dinner
time can be chaotic but with freshly
it's easy their chefs take care of your
meals a few nights a week and take the
pressure off of you freshly offered chef
made nutrient packed delicious meals
delivered fresh to your door there's no
cooking required that's what i'm talking
about grocery shopping and cooking can
be a pain especially right now and with
freshly you don't have to your meals
arrive cooked and fresh every week so
you can keep your fridge stocked and
skip a trip to the store ordering is
easy visit freshly.com and choose from
over 30 delicious satisfying better for
you meals like the steak peppercorn the
sausage baked penne or their chicken
pesto bowl look i love the chicken pesto
bowl i love the sausage baked penne and
the steak peppercorn they're great
they're a better option than when i come
home late whatever we're doing here at
the studio or shows i don't grab fast
food i get my freshly alright and
freshly can fit your lifestyle with a
variety of plans and meals to pick from
that work for your dietary needs your
preferences your taste and your family
size and now my listeners can try
freshly for just six dollars and 16
cents a meal that's cheaper than fast
food stop searching the internet for
healthy food near me every night and
start living life freshly your meals are
always delivered fresh never frozen and
they're ready to heat and enjoy in just
three minutes with new meals added each
week freshly brings the convenience of
chef made nutritionist design classics
right to your kitchen that's freshly.com
honeydew for forty dollars off your
first two orders all right right now
freshly's offering my listeners 40 bucks
off your first two orders when you go to
freshly.com honeydew stop stressing
about dinner go to freshly.com
honeydew for 40 off your first two
orders that's f r e s h l y dot com
slash honeydew our next sponsor is
sheath now sheath are boxers that are
designed to keep your balls off your
legs y'all sheath has three individual
compartments all right you can figure
out what they're for to keep everything
down there separate and cool and
comfortable all right traditional boxer
briefs are barbaric they're invented
during the neanderthal era and sheath
has a modern ergonomic design intended
to prevent that skin on skin contact for
long durations which you all know can
build up heat and sweat alright sheath
prevents all that it's the holy grail of
underwear there's an inverted kangaroo
pouch for your joey to keep from
sticking to your thigh all right you
will chafe and readjust less because
everything is in a separate compartment
because everything is separate and
there's less smell too all right they
were invented by a u.s army soldier who
came up with the idea for sheath during
his second tour in iraq where it was hot
as hell and his boys needed to breathe
all right he invented these underwear to
keep your boys cool and comfortable okay
dude's a hero he's like uh
i don't know he's like the elon musk of
ball bags i guess all right because
sheath underwear what you need in your
life if you want to be a modern man all
right now here we go listen up here's
what you got to do
go to sheath underwear dot com slash
honeydew for 20 off your order today i'm
gonna spell it for you that's s
h e a t h
underwear dot com slash honeydew and
make sure to use the promo code honey do
a check out that sheath underwear dot
com slash honeydew for 20 off and
do the right thing by your balls guys
they'll thank you all right 20 off
sheath underwear.com now let's get back
to the duke
and so did your parents come see you at
all
as
a comedian when you started out when i
first started
the sex so the first
time i did it i won the
and the contest
was that you got to open
or you got to do a guest spot on that
sunday
and who was your who's the headline the
amazing win or the incredible win i
don't know that so he was one of my
favorites he was always on he was a prop
comic that was always on make me laugh
when comedy central was like a baby okay
and he was just
[ __ ] devastating and sort of like
show up
and like immediately be opening for like
one of your favorites in front but then
you realize immediately the reason they
have you do the sunday show is because
you're going to bring the audience
because they're not they're all coming
to see it's a sunday show yeah so they
think if we put them up here then he'll
and i i did i brought like eight of my
because it was father's day oh man so
i'm at father's day like yeah i want a
contest i'm super [ __ ] funny you all
know it
and i'm confident around my family and
uh
and so
my aunts and uncles come out your dad
there on father's day
i'm sure he was i don't remember maybe
not
uh i remember there being a lot of
people there and just me eating
a giant dick in front of like an example
and they didn't they never came back
they didn't come back for years
years
they don't condemn you you get one shot
also that was like the non-artistic side
of the that was the very athletic side
of the family so they just show up and
like oh well that's as good as you are
you'll never be better
you're peaking right now you're picking
your second time up they never took them
into consideration
[Laughter]
so comedy pulls you out of this
depression
and
how are things at home like did your mom
like who were you closest to
throughout that at least your mom uh my
dad my mom and i always my mom and i my
mom again is one of my best friends but
she was
always very much concerned with me being
the best person i can be
rather than us being friends
all right and so a mom that led to us
being the best of friends when i got old
enough to recognize that
um but
so like my dad was always the guy we'd
have beers and i'd [ __ ] tell him what
was up and you know comedy for the first
year was just a hobby like i only did it
on mondays
and so still went to school everything
was great and then after the first six
months seven months
where i and then i start getting like
weekends and stuff like that and it
starts becoming a little more serious
and now i'm like
you know there was definitely a period i
was a house emcee at stanford's i'd go
to college from 7 to 11 in the morning
go straight from college to work at the
mall from 11 to 6. what store at the
mall i was security for the entire mall
you were secure you were mall security
for the whole ball we
i was at the rich mall so we just drove
bmws around a [ __ ] parking lot oh you
didn't even have a golf cart
i was driving an x5
i swear to god
yeah
and so i would just park that [ __ ] in
the parking lot what's the craziest [ __ ]
you see go down to our mall security so
this poor bastard
uh
they had just had a credit card fraud
seminar the night before okay right the
police department came in and said
here's how you find credit card fraud
this [ __ ] walks in that morning
and is like throws down this fake ass
credit card to the point where like the
guest attendant kind of thought it was a
test
like they're like yeah oh this so they
called security and it's like it's
the mall just opened i'm still eating
breakfast like i'll just sit there and
i'd eat my omelet because there wasn't
[ __ ] to do it's just mall walkers and
[ __ ] next time you get a call they're
like we have a possible credit card from
the guest store and so
we post up outside post it on your post
we post up outside
and just wait for them to walk out now
you have to realize that i am again the
black sheep i'm just working this gig
because it's easy and all my friends who
want to be cops work there
i don't want to bust anybody i just want
to go back to my car and [ __ ]
continue to write jokes so this guy
comes out and we're like hey you need to
stop and this [ __ ] takes off
around him
and i it was like one and i'm the cop
that's like [ __ ]
like so we take off run we're bolting
through a dillards
this dude takes out a woman like to the
point like we were going to tackle him
but we were afraid we were going to hurt
her yeah he picks the one day it snows
so we chase him outside we all tackle
him how many of you guys there were
three of us three of you
we
and i'm just like i'm not we're getting
eight bucks an hour yeah i'm fighting
i'm not fighting like literally the
other two dudes went down i was like
i'll cover make sure no one else
uh but yeah that was someone that was
like the craziest moment where i was
like what the [ __ ] is going on
and um
but yeah so i worked my security from
eleven to seven and then would go and i
remember eleven to six go home eat
dinner watch law and order and then
[ __ ] go do the shows and what it's
stanford's at stanford and westport and
that was the only club at the time in
casey time yeah and i was the house so
it was every week
okay good all right so you're really
getting up a lot i'm really getting up a
lot and
so then i start getting so then i start
doing like feature weeks and stuff like
that and then it just kind of got to a
point where i was like
i can go to college anytime but this
comedy shit's really taken off and i
need to take advantage of it and there
it hell broke loose like mom cried
[ __ ] there was a lot of screaming
really no not at all screaming you
screaming
dreamy just because they want you to go
in the navy or they wanted you to do
anything maybe the navy was out sounds
like you have good parents
they were just like but they were like
you can also do comedy at any time i'm
like no
no no no no you gotta take take
advantage of this [ __ ] when you're young
because you never know and who knows
what happens if i go to college i meet
some chick i get pregnant now i just i
need to focus on this college will
always be there and they're like
we fought it and it wasn't i fought more
mom or dad mom mom screaming screaming
yeah what did she really want you to do
go to college just have a degree in my
pocket so that i had something to fall
back on okay
to her credit even as successful as i've
been in my career there have definitely
been moments where i wish i had done
that you do yeah because there were just
moments
especially like 2011 and [ __ ] like when
career wasn't going so well like right
after last comic standing and there i
was like just like in the middle of this
weird
career desert where it was like
and i just had enough like the road
wasn't so i had the last comic standing
thing which was which led to another
huge depression because
as you grow up to be
as you come up as a stand-up comic and
you're fighting your head's down and
you're in the trenches of being a
feature act on the road
all you're thinking is
as soon as i get money
i will be happy
because i have everything else and then
i got money and i was still a miserable
piece of [ __ ] and i still had no
confidence and that led to like well
what the [ __ ] now
like i basically achieved most of my
goals at 27
and i still don't think i'm worth the
[ __ ] and
so that so in the middle of all of that
there was definitely a time where i was
contemplating walking away from
everything you were yeah and just
doing what what would you have done that
was the thing i went to type up a resume
i had no employable skills
the last job i had i was 19.
yeah
you try to dress up being a stand-up
comic as being an employable skill like
i can handle crowds like the [ __ ]
they see right all they see is some guy
that drank for [ __ ] 12 hours a day
and then worked for an hour
so i just and i remember
uh we i come from a very heavily
catholic family same and we're at a
we're at a family function father our
family priest showed up and he's a great
guy
and he someone asked him a question and
he had a great like
story
to tell that like was kind of a parable
and i was like i need to [ __ ] sit
down with this dude
and i i go father dawn can can i buy a
beer and we just kind of sit and talk
one time he's like you're speaking my
language
and
it was so
uninspiring
will you go and have beer and i was like
i go listen i've been a comic for this
many years it's not it went well and now
it's not going so well and i you know i
would like i'm not going to find a wife
this way and blah blah and
uh he just went i don't know you have
money in savings and i was like a little
bit he's like yeah i can move back see
what happens i was just like that is not
now i'm definitely not moving back yeah
when jesus i wanted a story where is
[ __ ] noah in this [ __ ] don't you have
something about footprints
come on
isn't there like a successory scene here
somewhere
did jesus ever do an open mind
when jesus was thinking about becoming a
feature a feature so
he's the middler jesus so there there
was definitely that moment in where i
thought about leaving everything and
just moving back to kansas city and
i don't know it would have been it would
have been bad if i'd done it but then i
got and then i got
to do ugly and angry and that went on
you know i was like the first generation
of specials to get on netflix
and it [ __ ] changed i mean that
special
uh more than any have changed changed
everything it like i think it really
solidified me as an actual
comedian because last comic standing
there have been a lot of great comics on
that show absolutely yeah that show did
not make them though like they that show
is kind of like this like prop yeah that
show
showcased them it didn't make them
exactly like amy schumer eliza like the
biggest ones
that was like a stepping stone to get to
the thing that blew them the [ __ ] yes
and um
you know i the thing about last comic
standing is it's it's a really great run
especially
we got in our season
our agents put on our tour so we made a
[ __ ] ton of money and then nbc got wind
of how much money we made and they're
like oh we're going to make that money
oh is that right dude the people that
were in the seasons behind me they'd
call and see what they were making and i
i felt sorry like it was a fifth of what
was a fifth a fifth yeah
and i mean i'm not surprised at all
that's why i do all i'm trying to do all
this [ __ ] myself now uh all of it myself
so yeah so then ugly and angry came
around and really started like that's
when my fans started to generate that's
when these people were coming to see me
and knew my jokes i got one question for
you yeah did those relatives come back
at this point
when i shot this because that's why i
was like i'm shooting the special in
kansas city because i'm going to let
these [ __ ] yeah
and and i think that comes back to
what you were saying like i don't i know
what i deserve but i
at the same time i don't think i deserve
it like that weird thing and i was like
this is my channel i'm coming home and
you know in my mind this place was gonna
be sold out and it was gonna be great in
reality it was
a fifth full and we made it look good
but um it was definitely
last comic standing solidified
everything for me because they they had
watch parties and [ __ ] so after that my
family was once you're on tv they can't
argue with you anymore no especially in
kansas right where they think it's all
real
and so
once once i got on tv ever you know mom
and dad stopped bitching and also i was
i
rarely needed money
i was always making pretty good money so
uh they couldn't really [ __ ] about that
but
again um
yeah it's so it the depression comes and
it goes still still now do you have any
kind of cte or any of that long term
anything if i do i'm not aware of it
yeah um you get headaches do you have
any kind of side effects from it not
from that like i had a headache nothing
no that's amazing it really is i got
jumped years ago and
they kicked my jaw and broke it and i
have tmj from it now like it it'll click
when i open too far oh yeah and anytime
i'm not a big drinker but if i do have a
drink
the next morning the hangover for me is
never in my head it's all
my [ __ ] jaw really i don't even [ __ ]
with it hardly yeah no i don't have weed
physically i have no well one of the
reasons
it's one of the reasons oh no i you know
i think weed is what i mean it is my
kalanapan or whatever did you were they
did they tell you to use that when you
were going through no i guess a lot of
my relatives are on it yeah and they
kind of seem to be of the same
especially i have a cousin
who's got a [ __ ] to get like i didn't
know he was on it until he told me
and uh like because he's
straight as an arrow
uh is an engineer actually does work for
the navy
and uh it's like
you know tried and true like a mr
america and he was like yeah i'm on
kalanapan yeah really yeah yeah yeah
and you you in your email you said a
cousin you found out something else
about another cousin oh so i had a
cousin that's not the same not the same
cousin this guy my other cousin uh
was like he and i were
best friends i mean not that me and the
other cousin weren't either but so i'm
like eight years older than any of my
cousins like they had me way early
and so my youngest cousin is or my
oldest cousin is
still eight years younger than i am and
but
we were always very close uh even when
we were kids growing up and like
he had like a lawn service and i'd go
when i'd go home and didn't have [ __ ] to
do i'd [ __ ] hop in his truck and go
mow yards with you like i just loved
hanging out with him and then
[ __ ] got weird like
like he would he would come and get me
and we'd work one day and then the night
he'd like i'll pick you up at like 10
tomorrow and won't go works and he
wouldn't show up like at all
and
then he'd call at like four and be like
oh sorry bro
and my dad my dad kept going like man i
think he's on something i think he's on
something i was like but eric's also
been weird
always like right that's when it's tough
to tell this is the same kid that
completely sober pulled his braces off
with needle nose pliers because he was
tired yeah he's that
like
so and
yeah he had some like played rookie ball
for the royals
[ __ ] got his jaw crushed by a 98 mile
an hour fastball
and still got up and tried to charge the
mound
damn really he goes i got up
and he goes i could feel my jaw was in
two pieces and i knew something was
wrong and then i he goes and i spit out
like three teeth and i just said i'll
[ __ ] let him go
and you know i don't know if that led to
where he is now but
and it was just like and i'd be like
that's [ __ ] no he's just weird like
of all and i'm i'm pretty hip man like i
can tell when people are [ __ ] up and i
can usually tell you which drugs they're
on now to be fair i
know nothing about meth i've never been
around it i you know and i'm i guess i
don't hang out at [ __ ]
walmarts enough or whatever
but it was just i've seen a lot of drugs
and meth is one of the few drugs that
i've never seen in my entire life and so
uh and then yeah he got popped for it he
got popular he got popped with a bunch
of it how much is a bunch i'd like
enough to where it was an issue really
yeah yeah federal issue uh federal
prison issues no but enough to where he
was looking at some time and this was
post like the um baseball and all this
stuff baseball and he still got the on
service but again shit's getting weird
and and then
you know my dad's screaming he's like
dude he's on something he's on and then
and is this your dad's brother or sister
sisters
it's my mom's sister's kid okay and i'm
just like he's just not i mean this is a
kid that i got high and he [ __ ]
freaked out on wheat yeah so i'm like
there's no way he's getting into up like
[ __ ] that's
zero to a thousand yeah i was wrong
and it was just i mean it was just the
weirdest
because of like if if i would have bet
on the 15 cousins
which ones were going to get addicted to
that [ __ ] he would have been
[ __ ] 14 really yeah
just because he was all he ever did was
work out and
figure out how to get bigger and
stronger and he loved to work out and
when i would
when i first started going back to the
gym he like wrote my workouts for me
and
like he was just nothing but how do i
get healthier and better and
for him to then go
also i'm going to do this [ __ ] that rots
my face from the inside out teeth yeah
it just made no sense and also
he was asleep most the time like i
thought if you're on meth
you're supposed to be doing sherwin's
the one you're sleeping yeah no this guy
he never you know it just never made
sense to me and to have it was just such
a kick in the balls to have a guy that
you think you know so well
and then
also you're like what could i have
what what else did i miss and then when
you look back on it there's nothing you
ever really there was once there was one
time and again eric was weird as [ __ ] uh
still is
uh
but like we stopped at a gas station to
get gas and then he was gone for like 45
minutes
and then you know i lost track of time
because i think i was on my side
probably and i just figured i was like
this guy's i just figured he's dropping
one
and
it was taking a while maybe there's a
backup on the poop train i don't know
and but then he just showed up and he
just kind of
like didn't really tell me what the [ __ ]
was going on and that was the only time
where i was like okay this is [ __ ]
weird like where where the [ __ ] were you
while i was at i was literally just
parked at a gas pump for 45 minutes
just suddenly in the passenger seat with
no keys
couldn't pull it couldn't go
you pop it in neutral we'll push this
[ __ ] like i
and it was just
so yeah it was so weird just to be
[ __ ]
you know in such a [ __ ] dark and to
me it's always been such like a white
trash drug it's like a shitty you would
think so but it's not no
[Music]
but it does it it reeks of white trash
because you can make it at home in a
[ __ ] soda bottle and [ __ ] you know
what i mean that's what you're seeing
but also it's like i've never been to a
party where it was like [ __ ] gary's
got meth
never no yeah
nor would i hang out at that party
at all yeah that [ __ ] you shut up about
and you know who does it and that's it
yeah dude i get freaked out when i go
into like head shops and they you go to
the shitty ghetto ones and then they
have like the meth accessories and
you're just like i get the willies
and yeah so it was just
that was a giant kick in the balls just
to [ __ ]
you know and he's in jail now he is yeah
he got popped from that
no excuse me he
he he was always trying to he's always
trying to get the easy way out trying to
one-up people like i remember we'd go
i'd meet him at a movie and he'd buy a
child's ticket
and just see if they'd catch him and if
not he saved three bucks and if like he
had no shame right and so he was j he's
always that kid and uh so he got popped
for like
online gambling fraud
he's just taking people's money i don't
know i remember back in the day he'd be
like well if you you can sign up for
this site they give you 500 and you pull
out and then you can do this and it was
like that i'm like that already sounds
like first off i don't need to be
gambling first you lost me when you said
sign up yeah
i only gamble when i'm on
yeah yeah no i'm not leaving my credit
card on that side yeah i only gamble in
vegas and that's rarely yeah that's when
i get drunk and go put 30 bucks on the
royals to win
yeah yeah yeah
so but yeah it was
it's just it's just weird
and so he's in jail now he's in jail now
as far as i know
i don't know they're working it's not
for too long i don't think you are you
in touch prior to that no it was
you know he he would disappear and he
would come back and then i remember he
was at like christmas like two years ago
and he was just [ __ ] jacked yes and
he had been home and working out and
then
and then he disap and then he was like
and he was all very much like you know
i'm so glad i'm through this and like my
family's what kept got me out of it and
then as soon as christmas was over boom
gone
and i think what a lot of it is is
for him especially is just boredom like
he doesn't
he's never really had a job
that he could keep for too long because
he likes to run his mouth and also tries
to find
the easy way around [ __ ] and um he's
also the guy that bad luck also tends to
find him usually so but then he gets
bored
and then he starts feeding him and then
he he leaves and then he's gone for days
and days and days sometimes months
and then they they had heard from him
like thanksgiving like his mom texted
him and he texted back and then
does anybody know where he goes
no not really and then they got a call
from the authorities that he was in
nebraska
re and that's where he's locked up right
now he's locked up yeah [ __ ] i don't
want to be locked up out there
yeah
i bet that prison's cold i've been i
made that move i've been to nebraska
you've been it's just a bunch of corn
eating yeah man those big boys in there
too will [ __ ] you up yeah yeah
no those are the dudes that like they
like take it from you while they're
staring at you yeah whatever they want
yeah kind of guy i'm gonna look
so what are you in for cow rape oh [ __ ]
all right
yeah yeah no you win
you want my pillow and all my biscuits
sorry everything i know about prison i
learned from 60 days in so
so right now with your health and
everything going on there's nothing from
the brain surgery i mean not that i'm
acutely awake what do they tell you
obviously you can't play football but
what else well i think now i could
really yeah i think the brain shield i
remember i went in for my you know
you're 17 and you're
you have these disney dreams of like oh
you healed magically and uh i walked
into the doctor and he
i go uh
so can i play football and he just
laughed he's like no man he's like
you can play golf i was like go [ __ ]
yourself i think i just told him to go
[ __ ] for real and then
they were gonna clear me to play
basketball but i had i hadn't played
since my eighth grade year just because
by the time football was over my body
was
needed a break from all that [ __ ] and so
um i so i was like i'll go play
basketball and i went in and talked to
the coach and he was like look man you
haven't played for three years
he was like you're gonna have to be
really [ __ ] good to make the team
and he was like are you really [ __ ]
good and i was like no he's like yeah
then i can enjoy your senior year yeah
kind of thanks but no thanks
and uh so yeah i was out of sports
i might have played golf my senior year
went so remember music was always in
your family wait i want to ask this real
quick the wires yeah do they do they
have to be taken out no they're in there
and they don't they don't click anymore
but they're there they're there do you
have any trouble going through metal
detectors not at all i think they pot
they may pop up on an x-ray all right
but that's about it yeah no i've never
had
any issue you know my
you know my depression that comes around
every once in a while maybe from that i
don't know but it also just like i said
might be just for my inner [ __ ]
conquer your inner business
what um
music for you so you have a musical
family yeah and not like
you know it's not like the gaither
family where like everyone plays like
everyone does play you mentioned your
uncle made money who's your uncle so my
uncle norm
was in a band called the elders and they
were a huge
i mean for that scene celtic rock band
that traveled
they basically played every irish
festival in the country and they they
they did very well for themselves and um
they're in like hall of music hall of
fames and places and oh wow all right
and then mikey play he plays bass okay
and then um my other uncle jeff
was just an incredibly talented man that
just never
took a risk and left town and tried to
be
the next thing i they they were on star
search in like 1983 i think
and uh
but yeah i don't think he answered me
but eventually uh started playing guitar
for this guy named bob walken horst who
was in a band called the rainmakers in
the 80s that
were big
in norway of all places so he went out
there and got to like live finally live
that rock star life we're playing a
theater
and really light show and really rocking
out so
you know he definitely got to live his
dream eventually i don't know if it was
in the facet that he had hoped but
um but yeah we it wasn't like a thing
where we all sit around during the
holidays and play guitar as a matter of
fact if you
it was if you weren't very good they
didn't let you play at all oh really
there wasn't like the make-a-wish moment
where they just left
a witch it was like okay
let chris play a little bit it was like
wrong note give me that [ __ ] [ __ ] and
so
and now like they come over and hang out
and like me and my cousins will start
playing a little bit in our own place
but you're really passionate about it
josh adam meyers told me a story about
you and he and i
quote you all the time you don't even
know this this is what's this is so
great it's a quote that we throw back
and forth and it's a chris porter quote
and i wasn't even there he told me it
was back when
um angelo was still here and um you guys
used to jam after the comedy show and
you guys are all sitting around and you
take it so seriously and or maybe it was
at the comedy store one night because i
think you guys did there too and
everyone's farting around trying to
figure out what to play and everything
and he said you just spoke up and said
you're wasting time and then you went
right into soul shine which i [ __ ]
love
i
he and i now back and forth rip on uh we
just i tell him if we're doing i'm like
you're wasting time
i was like i love that yeah man i just
love the music so i just i was like what
let's just play something uh music's a
great like everything i am as a stand-up
comedian is in my failure to be a rock
star i feel like and it helped did music
help you through your depression do you
turn to music at all i play guitar every
morning i wake up every day yeah wow um
acoustic yeah when i'm home i don't take
it with me but and what do you play your
own stuff no i mean i have
i wrote a couple of songs last year
trying to get over somebody and that was
the first time
i had written anything uh
but i just i felt the need to
and i wrote and that led to me writing
like five or six songs that are
okay i guess but no no mainly it's just
songs that i like i'm always trying to
learn a new song and maybe a new chord
just to make myself better have you ever
released any of your music i put stuff
on instagram but to be honest with you
the stuff i put on and the stuff i've
recorded it's like 10
because it's like
i'm always like oh this sounds good and
as soon as i start recording i'll watch
it back and then that's when the inner
[ __ ] comes in and you're just like i'm
with you you're like no no no we're not
showing that and as a matter of fact
even the stuff that i put up like i
can't i have to just put it up and like
pretend it's not even that's a [ __ ] yeah
yeah i did [ __ ] up that one no just let
it go
what um
[Music]
like
do you ever
get
inspired for comedy from your music from
your music
like the music that i write yeah like i
for me like i'll explain what i mean
better here like when i hear music
i
in my mind i will create funny scenes
okay you know what i mean i'll put that
song i'm hearing right now to
some sort of funny
scene that i think i could shoot or a
promo or a moment in a movie or a show
that i could use somehow that's and i
love the lyrics i'm big big big on
lyrics but
the feel of of the music and what i do
with it visually is
i don't know if you ever do that the way
what music does for me is it just helps
in the writing process especially
because like comedy i feel especially my
comedy
you can only draw from really like three
or four emotions and anger confusion
you know there's not a lot of happy
jokes
you know not a lot of jokes ah such a
great day today
um and then like
sometimes you know especially like i've
been trying to get over somebody
you know you write jokes that you think
are jokes and then you go back and it's
it's a [ __ ] journal entry is all it
is
like you just read you're like [ __ ] none
of this is funny you were just laughing
because it hurt a little bit it's like
stubbing your toe or something
and so if if i have trouble getting
through it or if it's
an emotion that i'm trying to deal with
that isn't anger or confusion then i'll
start to write music
which allows me to kind of get through
that to get on to writing and so in that
facet it helps
uh
but yeah and i and i do think of my bits
more like songs
in the fact that's interesting they
usually put a special together an album
together do you think like that yeah
it's like okay well this you know
everything's got to kind of move and and
flow into each other
and it's like so i mean i do that also
but mostly
i mean i i like an a to z flow and i
like a build and a start and an end an
arc and all that but
having um
you know putting it in a certain place
for me
naturally makes me just flow right into
that thing next without having to be
like what am i going to talk what am i
talking about next yeah i'm going from
my dad [ __ ] to this you know i try to
put it together like that too in some
ways it's also like
i don't even think about the bid itself
is like because most of the bits that i
do especially lately like it's about who
they're about and so i just remember oh
this is
that's so-and-so's bit and this is and
then it's
for that and i but i also feel like if
i'm
working from that angle then it allows
me to get back into the emotions that
got me there in the first place so that
the joke has a little more authenticity
because i'm genuinely thinking the same
thing i thought when i wrote it right
yeah this has been a great episode man
thank you for coming on and being so
open and honest about all that well
thanks for having me it was kind of you
know it's like i said i hadn't said a
lot of this [ __ ] out loud so i
appreciate you doing that i know that
wasn't easy yeah so it's um
so thank you yeah thank you man so
here's the question i ask all my first
time guests now um after everything
we've talked about knowing everything we
know about you now what advice would you
give to your 16 year old self
um
[Music]
try to [ __ ] those chicks
i'm dead serious
[ __ ] [ __ ] get money pretty much cause
like you look back at high school and
you're like
like four of those chicks totally would
have [ __ ] me
if i would have shown any effort
whatsoever
but here's what i love about that you
got hit by a golf ball a year later and
it didn't hey stand on the right side of
your mom no
dude if i'm talking to the kid that's
going golfing i'm like lean left
try to get that you know
because
that golf ball is the best thing ever
happened to me not getting laid during
high school
could you imagine i mean i can't just a
all right just
i was lucky i got laid in high school i
was i lost my virginity at 15. god bless
you yeah i got lucky god bless her
right i can't even because you know that
[ __ ] wasn't good no i i i mean acne the
whole everything everything none of it
was good like god bless you young lady
thank you for real thank you thank you
sarah
dude my first was named sarah
up
top um please plug promote anything
you'd like go to chrisportercomedy.com
and fill in the blanks there it is all
right uh as always ryan sickler on all
social media ryan sickler.com we'll talk
to you all next week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you